Hallo ihr Lieben!
Ich backe heute meine eigene Geburtstagstorte!
Das ist nämlich der Vorteil wenn jeder aus dem Umfeld weiß, dass du gerne backst:
dann kriegt man keine mehr, dann macht man sie sich eben selber.
Und wir machen eine richtig leckere mit Vanillebiskuit, einem White Chocolate Frosting
- ich liebe alles was mit weißer Schokolade zu tun hat - und ein bisschen
Frucht ist auch noch mit dabei für's gute Gewissen.
Und jetzt zeig ich euch hier die Zutaten.
Hier habe ich meinen Vanillebiskuitboden gebacken, das Rezept dazu findet ihr schon auf meinem Kanal,
ich hab hier die Mengenangaben wie im Rezept genommen
mit dem einzigen Unterschied, dass ich das in zwei 22cm Springfromen
gebacken hab.
Desweiteren haben wir hier etwas Sahne, außerdem weiße Kuvertüre (gehackt),
Puderzucker, weiche Butter, etwas Aprikosenmarmelade
und Mandarinen aus der Dose.
Wir starten jetzt zuallererst mit der weißen Kuvertüre und der Sahne.
Die Sahne hab ich mir grad in der Mirkowelle erhitzt, sodass sie grad anfing,
hochzusteigen und jetzt geb ich das einmal über die gehackte weiße Kuvertüre.
Und jetzt den Deckel draufgeben und 5 Minuten ruhen lassen.
Nach 5 Minuten ist die Schokolade schon so ein bisschen in der heißen Sahne
geschmolzen und jetzt nehmen wir uns unseren Schneebesen
und verrühren das einmal, dass es alles schön glatt ist.
So, jetzt ist alles gut miteinander verbunden und wir haben
eine homogene Masse.
Die muss jetzt allerdings auskühlen, das dauert so 20-30 Minuten.
Dann können wir sie erst weiterverarbeiten.
So, die Ganache ist jetzt abgekühlt und wir können weitermachen.
Unser Frosting besteht ja aus Ganache und aus Butter und Puderzucker.
Ich gebe jetzt die weiche bzw. zimmerwarme Butter in die Schüssel
meiner Küchenmaschine, ihr könnt aber auch euer Handrührgerät verwenden,
dann dauert es nur ein bisschen länger.
So, jetzt gebe ich das einmal rein, Puderzucker gleich hinterher
und dann wird das schön cremig aufgeschlagen.
5 Minuten hat das Ganze jetzt bei mir gedauert in der Küchenmaschine,
mit dem Handrührgerät schlagt die Butter etwa 8 Minuten lang cremig
und dann ist die richtig schön hell.
Und an der Stelle geben wir jetzt auch noch die Ganache mit rein
und arbeiten sie in einem dünnen Strahl mit ein.
So, jetzt ist die Ganache auch mit drin, alles schön untergerührt
und jetzt ist unser Frosting bzw. die White Chocolate Buttercream auch schon fertig.
An der Stelle ist es noch ein bisschen weich, aber ich geb euch einen Tipp
falls ihr das besser verstreichen könnt auf dem Kuchen, wenn es etwas
härter ist als das hier, dann gebt's einfach in den Kühlschrank
für etwa 20 Minuten, rührt ständig um und dann könnt ihr das
ganz einfach einstreichen.
Um unsere Geburtstagstorte jetzt fertig zu stellen, müssen wir zuallererst
die Böden durchschneiden. Hier hab ich noch einen Tipp für euch:
Damit eure Böden nicht austrocknen einfach ein feuchtes Küchentuch
drumherum legen oder in Frischhaltefolie einwickeln, je nachdem,
was ihr gerade da habt.
Und jetzt werd ich die ein Mal in der Mitte halbieren, sodass
ich 4 Böden insgesamt erhalte.
Und jetzt werden wir die Torte nur noch zusammenstellen, ich hab mir hier dafür
meine süße Tortenplatte zurechtgelegt. Das ist so eine kleine - meine
Lieblingstortenplatte - (H: Komm, zeig sie mal!)
Die hat der Hamza mir mal geholt (H: Jaa!)
Und genau da werd ich jetzt das Ganze stapeln und dann müssen wir
es auch nicht mehr hin und her transportieren.
Jetzt nehm ich mir den ersten Boden, leg den drauf und
dann geben wir da noch unsere Aprikosenmarmelade drauf
und Mandarinen und anschließend die Creme
und dann stapeln wir die immer so weiter.
Und falls ihr es ganz gerade möchtet und so ein bisschen Hilfe braucht,
dann gebt da ruhig so einen Backrahmen drumherum
und dann könnt ihr das auch richtig ordentlich stapeln.
Und falls ihr euch jetzt fragt, ob ihr hier irgendwas austauschen könnt,
das ist garkein Thema. Falls ihr Kirschen da habt, gebt die
gerne rein. Bananen passen auch super, Erdbeeren, Himbeeren,
gerne auch Tiefkühlfrüchte.
Und die Marmelade könnt ihr auch durch jede beliebige andere austauschen
oder durch Nuss-Nougat Creme, ist auch super lecker.
Jetzt ist die Torte randvoll gefüllt, jetzt geb ich nur noch den Deckel
oben drauf und zum Abschluss nehm ich gerne so ein richtig gerades
Stück, das ist der Tortenboden, also das untere Teil gewesen.
Einfach drauf geben, Frischhaltefolie darüber geben
damit das auch nicht austrocknet und dann muss es einmal durchkühlen,
am besten 1 bis 1 ½ Stunden, und dann (H: Warum flüsterst du so?)
Jaa weil viele sind immer ungeduldig und sagen: "Muss das so lange kühlen?" aber
dann wird's einfach leckerer!
So! Also bis gleich!
Nach der Kühlzeit müssen wir jetzt einmal das Äußere komplett einstreichen,
ich hatte die Buttercreme in der Zwischenzeit auch im Kühlschrank
und jetzt ist der Kuchen richtig schön fest, einmal schön glatt einstreichen.
Und dann geht's nämlich weiter mit der finalen Dekoration.
Sobald ihr mit der Torte zufrieden seid und sie rundherum eingestrichen habt,
geben wir an den unteren Rand noch Konfetti oder Streusel -
also essbares Konfetti - und danach wird sie wieder eingefroren aber
jetzt kümmern wir uns erstmal um die bunten Streusel.
So ihr Lieben, meine Torte ist jetzt im Gefrierfach, ich hab mir da
wie gesagt ein bisschen Platz gemacht, da dauert's ungefähr
20 Minuten bis es hart wird, im Kühlschrank denk ich so 30-40 Minuten
und einen Teil der Creme hab ich mir jetzt an die Seite getan in einem Spritzbeutel
damit ich gleich nochmal den Kuchen richtig schön dekorieren kann.
Und für die weitere Dekoration - wir machen nämlich einen Dripcake - benötigen wir
außerdem noch weiße Kuvertüre, die hab ich fein gehackt,
bzw. ein bisschen gröber aber das macht nichts. Außerdem
etwas Sahne und hier hab ich pinke Lebensmittelfarbe,
das ist Gelfarbe und die rühre ich sofort in die Sahne ein
und anschließend wird die Sahne aufgekocht.
Die Sahne hab ich jetzt erneut in der Mikrowelle aufkochen lassen,
das gleiche Prinzip wie gerade und die geb ich jetzt auch mit zur Kuvertüre,
decke das ab und dann lassen wir das 5 Minuten stehen,
etwas anschmelzen und dann wird das Ganze verrührt.
Nach den 5 Minuten verrühren wir wieder alles miteinander
bis wir eine homogene Masse erhalten und so könnt ihr eben Ganache färben.
Nur Kuvertüre färben mit Pastenfarbe funktioniert nicht,
da würde sich alles lösen und ihr würdet nur Klumpen erhalten,
dafür braucht man schon so bestimmte Pulverfarbe, die fettlöslich ist
aber das ist eben eine super Alternative, dann braucht ihr keine Candymelts kaufen
die sind ja auch nicht gerade günstig.
Genau und jetzt verrühre ich das miteinander und dann sehen wir mal
das Endergebnis.
(H: Danke für den Tipp Kiki!)
So, fertig eingefärbt und ich finde die Farbe sieht richtig cool aus!
Ihr könnt natürlich auch jede andere Farbe nehmen,
falls z.B. jemand Geburtstag hat, der männlich ist, könnt ihr
euch hier blaue Farbe reinmischen, ganz wie ihr möchtet
oder jemand hat ne Lieblingsfarbe, das geht auch.
Und jetzt geb ich das einfach auf die Oberfläche und verteile das so
mit meiner Winkelpalette, dass es an den Seiten runtertropft.
Nachdem wir unseren Drip runterfließen lassen haben,
hab ich das nochmal kurz in den Kühlschrank gegeben, damit das fest wird
das dauert auch nur 10 Minuten, also nicht allzu lange
und jetzt geben wir die Creme noch drauf und dann
haben wir den Kuchen fertig dekoriert.
Und, hab ich's euch nicht gesagt?
Wenn ihr diese Torte seht, dann werdet ihr sagen: "Das ist die ultimative Geburtstagstorte!"
Die schreit nur so nach Happy Birthday, finde ich!
(H: Für Mädchen aber nur!)
Genau, für Mädchen wegen der Farbe.
Muss nicht sein, vielleicht gibt's ja auch Jungs, die mögen Pink, Hamza!
Kann ja auch sein.
Ansonsten könnt ihr auch gerne andere Farben...haa, jetzt sagst du nichts mehr, ne?
Auf jeden Fall super lecker, ich kenn ja die Buttercreme schon,
die gefällt mir super gut mit der weißen Schokolade,
mit den Früchten ein super Ausgleich!
Und alle genauen Zutaten findet ihr hier unten in der Infobox.
Ein Memo noch an mich selbst: Nie wieder mit Fledermausärmeln Kuchen backen!
Also das ist total dreckig, ich kann's euch mal zeigen
Sieht man das?
Schade, egal. Man lernt ja auch immer was dazu!
Ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel Spaß beim Nachmachen.
Hinterlasst dem Video gerne ein Like und einen Kommentar,
abonniert meinen Kanal kostenlos, damit ihr auch nichts mehr verpasst
und dann freue ich mich, wenn wir uns auch beim nächsten Mal sehen.
Tschüss!
(H: Kiki?) Ja?
(H: Happy Birthday!) Ist erst morgen, aber Danke!
(H: Gerne doch!)